how to batch in boost together
in this video we'll see how to batch
input sequences together
in general the sentences we want to pass
through our model
we want to allow the same length here we
are using the model we saw
in the sentiment analysis pipeline and
want to classify
two sentences when tokenizing them and
mapping each token to its corresponding
input ids
we get two lists of different lengths
trying to create a tensor on a bi array
from those two lists
will result in an error because all
arrays and 10 source
should be rectangular one way to
overcome this limit is to make the
second sentence the same length as the
first
by adding a special token as many times
as necessary
another way would be to truncate the
first sequence to the length of the
second
but we would then lose a lot of
information that may be necessary to
properly classify the sentence
in general we only truncate sentences
when they are longer than the maximum
length the model can handle
the value used to pass the second
sentence should not be picked randomly
the model has been pre-trained with a
certain padding id which you can find
in tokenizer.pad tokenity
now that we have padded our sentences we
can make a batch with them
if we pass the two sentences to the
models separately or patched together
however
we notice that we don't get the same
results for the sentence that is padded
here the second one is that the bug in
the transformers library
no if you remember that transformer
models make av use of attention layers
this should not come as a total surprise
when computing the contextual
representation of each token
the attention layers look at all the
other words in the sentence
if we have just the sentence or the
sentence with several padding tokens
added
is surgical we don't get the same values
to get the same results with or without
padding we need to indicate to the
attention layers
that we should ignore the spanning
tokens this is done by creating an
attention
mask a tensor with the same shape as the
input ids
with zeros and ones once
indicate the tokens the attention layers
should consider in the context
and zeroes the tokens we should ignore
now passing this attention mask along
with input ids
will give us the same results as when we
send the two sentences individually to
the model
this is all done behind the scenes by
the tokenizer when you apply it to
several sentences with the flag
padding equal to it will apply the
padding with a proper value to the
smaller sentences
and create the appropriate attention
mask